Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Two, Episode Two: the Folketing, the Danish parliament.
Picture the building on Slotsholmen in Copenhagen.
The Folketing is Denmark's parliament, and together with the government, it holds the legislative power.
It has its seat at Christiansborg in Copenhagen.
Let's start with the people.
The Folketing has 179 members.
Of these, 175 are elected in Denmark, 2 in the Faroe Islands, and 2 in Greenland.
At the latest general election, in 2026, 86 women were elected, which is 48 percent, and 93 men, which is 52 percent.
Members of the Folketing almost always belong to a political party, and the political debate in the Folketing typically takes place between the parties.
The individual members present their party's political views.
The Folketing's meetings are, as a starting point, public.
Anyone can come into the public gallery in the chamber and listen to the debates.
This openness is an important part of democracy.
The meetings are also recorded, so you can watch them online, on the Folketing's website.
Now to the calendar.
The Folketing year begins on the first Tuesday of October, when the Folketing meets after the summer holiday.
At that meeting, the prime minister gives a speech in which he or she gives an account of the state of the realm, that is, which challenges and opportunities the government sees, and what the government intends to do about them.
This speech is called the prime minister's opening speech.
The members of the Folketing then debate its content.
When the Folketing handles a proposal for a new law, it happens in the chamber at Christiansborg.
Here the members from the political parties discuss every bill before they finally vote on it.
Part of the legislative work also takes place in one of the many committees that the Folketing has set up.
Each year the Folketing passes, on average, about 200 bills.
One of them is the proposal for the finance act, the finanslov, which is the state's total budget for the next year.
The Folketing also decides who should have government power after an election.
According to the constitution, it is formally the king who appoints the government.
But the king must not appoint a government that has a majority in the Folketing against it.
That follows from the parliamentary principle.
When a new government is to be formed, a so-called king's round, a kongerunde, is often held.
In a king's round, two representatives of each party in turn go to the king to give advice on who they think should lead the negotiations on a new government, or who they think should be the new prime minister.
Based on the advice the king receives, he can either appoint the person who has the most seats behind them as negotiation leader, or point directly to a person who gets the task of forming a new government with themself as prime minister.
Now, how does the Folketing keep an eye on the government?
It is the government and the public administration that must put the laws into effect.
One of the Folketing's tasks is therefore to check that this happens the way the Folketing wanted.
Control can, for example, be carried out by an individual member asking a minister to answer a question orally or in writing.
This is the most common way of exercising control, and several thousand questions are put to the ministers every year.
One or more members can also raise an interpellation debate, a forespørgselsdebat.
It allows for a somewhat longer debate in the chamber.
The Folketing's standing, or permanent, committees can also call a minister in for a so-called consultation, a samråd.
The minister must then appear before the committee and answer questions on concrete political subjects.
In these ways, the Folketing can continuously follow the government's work and express its support for, or criticism of, the government.
If a majority in the Folketing is, for example, very dissatisfied with a minister, the Folketing can force this minister to resign by expressing its lack of confidence in the minister.
In practice, a minister often chooses to step down of their own accord if serious criticism is expressed.
A majority in the Folketing can also express its lack of confidence in the whole government.
That happens when a majority in the Folketing expresses its lack of confidence in the prime minister.
It is called a motion of no confidence, a mistillidsvotum.
The government must then resign, or the prime minister must call a new election.
During interpellation debates, the opposition often puts forward proposals that criticise the government's policy.
However, proposals that amount to a vote of no confidence in the government are rarely adopted.
But the possibility of doing so plays a significant role in the balance of power between the government and the opposition.
The Folketing's power over the government and the ministers is the core of parliamentarism.
The government and the individual ministers are thus politically accountable to the Folketing.
And if a minister is suspected of having done something illegal in the course of their work as minister, the Folketing or the government can decide to bring them before a special court, the Court of Impeachment, Rigsretten.
Since Rigsretten was introduced with the first constitution in 1849, only six impeachment cases have been brought against ministers.
Rigsretten consists of up to 15 judges from the Supreme Court, and just as many members who are elected by the Folketing for six years at a time.
The members elected by the Folketing cannot at the same time be members of the Folketing.
In recent times there have been two impeachment cases.
One was in connection with the so-called Tamil case, where a former minister of justice in 1995 was given a four-month suspended prison sentence for having prevented Tamil refugees from Sri Lanka from getting family reunification.
And in 2021, a former minister for immigration and integration was sentenced to 60 days of unconditional imprisonment for illegally separating asylum-seeking spouses and cohabiting couples at asylum centres.
That former minister for immigration and integration was Inger Støjberg, who later founded the party Danmarksdemokraterne, which you met in Chapter One.
Next: the workshops of the Folketing.
A large part of the Folketing's work takes place in the standing, or permanent, committees, which are set up by the Folketing.
They are often called the Folketing's workshops.
In the chamber, the big lines are drawn up, but it is in the committees that politics is discussed thoroughly and in detail.
The committees must deal with bills that are put forward.
When a bill has had its first reading in the chamber, it is normally sent for closer consideration in a committee.
Here, citizens or associations can, by agreement with the committee, come and present their views.
Everyone also has the opportunity to put forward their views by writing to the committee.
When the committee has finished handling a bill, a report is written, a betænkning.
It contains, among other things, the individual parties' positions on the bill.
The standing committees also exercise control over the individual minister.
A minister can, as mentioned, be called in for a consultation, and the committee's members can ask the minister questions.
Each standing committee typically deals with the political matters that belong to a specific ministry's area of responsibility.
The Folketing has, for example, a tax committee, a finance committee and an employment committee, because there is a tax ministry, a finance ministry and an employment ministry.
The Folketing also has other standing committees, for example a European Affairs Committee, which deals with matters concerning cooperation in the EU, and which originate from all ministries.
The number of committees varies.
There are normally between 20 and 25 standing committees.
The Folketing's committees consist only of members of the Folketing.
A committee typically has 29 members, including a chair and a deputy chair.
The committees are put together so that each party has a number of committee members that roughly corresponds to the party's size in the Folketing.
The idea is that a majority in a committee should reflect a majority in the Folketing.
According to the constitution, there must be a Foreign Policy Committee, Det Udenrigspolitiske Nævn.
The government has a duty to consult the Foreign Policy Committee before it makes a decision of major foreign policy importance.
That makes room for a broad political debate and broad political backing for the big foreign policy decisions, for example whether Denmark should use military force against another state, or enter into an important agreement with other countries.
Because cooperation in the EU is so extensive, a European Affairs Committee, Europaudvalget, has also been set up.
Its first and foremost task is to control Danish EU policy.
In larger cases, the government must therefore ask the European Affairs Committee for advice before it goes to negotiations in the EU.
On that basis, the committee gives the government a negotiating mandate.
The mandate sets out Denmark's position on the matter, including whether the government can vote for or against a proposal.
In this way, the European Affairs Committee gives the Folketing the opportunity to steer, for example, how the government votes at the meetings of the EU's Council of Ministers.
Here is your recap for Episode Two.
The Folketing has 179 members: 175 from Denmark, 2 from the Faroe Islands, and 2 from Greenland.
It sits at Christiansborg.
The Folketing year starts on the first Tuesday of October, with the prime minister's opening speech.
About 200 bills are passed per year, including the finance act.
The king formally appoints the government, after the king's round, but not against a majority in the Folketing.
A motion of no confidence forces the government to resign or call an election.
Rigsretten tries ministers: only six impeachment cases since 1849, with up to 15 Supreme Court judges and as many members elected by the Folketing for six years.
There are normally 20 to 25 standing committees, typically with 29 members.
The Foreign Policy Committee must be consulted on major foreign policy decisions, and the European Affairs Committee gives the government its negotiating mandate for the EU.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Can everyone, under normal circumstances, attend meetings in the Folketing chamber?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Kan alle under normale omstændigheder overvære møder i folketingssalen?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is A: Yes.
It appeared in the June 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Ja
Question 2.
Who can be a member of a committee in the Folketing?
Option A: Politicians who are members of the Folketing.
Option B: Civil servants employed in a ministry.
[DA] Hvem kan være medlem af et udvalg i Folketinget?  A: Politikere, der er medlemmer af Folketinget  |  B: Embedsmænd, der er ansat i et ministerium
The answer is A: Politicians who are members of the Folketing.
It appeared in the June 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Politikere, der er medlemmer af Folketinget
Question 3.
Which court convicted the former minister for immigration and integration, Inger Støjberg, of illegally separating asylum-seeking couples?
Option A: The High Court, Landsretten.
Option B: The Supreme Court, Højesteret.
Option C: The Court of Impeachment, Rigsretten.
[DA] Hvilken domstol dømte tidligere udlændinge- og integrationsminister Inger Støjberg for ulovligt at have adskilt asylsøgende par?  A: Landsretten  |  B: Højesteret  |  C: Rigsretten
The answer is C: The Court of Impeachment, Rigsretten.
It appeared in the June 2022 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Rigsretten
Question 4.
What did the Folketing's indictment in the impeachment case against the former minister Inger Støjberg concern, among other things?
Option A: Confiscation of refugees' valuables on entry.
Option B: A temporary stop to family reunifications.
Option C: Separation of asylum-seeking spouses and cohabiting couples.
[DA] Hvad omhandler Folketingets tiltale i rigsretssagen mod tidligere udlændinge- og integrationsmini- ster Inger Støjberg blandt andet?  A: Beslaglæggelse af flygtninges værdigenstande ved indrejse  |  B: Midlertidigt stop for familiesammenføringer  |  C: Adskillelse af asylsøgende ægtefæller og samlevende par
The answer is C: Separation of asylum-seeking spouses and cohabiting couples.
It appeared in the June 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Adskillelse af asylsøgende ægtefæller og samlevende par
That's the end of this part.
Well done.